[Música]
soy una apasionada de la innovación en
salud de la innovación que aporte valor
y de los cambios disruptivos que busquen
océanos azules
hoy estoy aquí para contaros una
historia hace cinco años comencé a
trabajar en proyectos tecnológicos en
salud y tuve la oportunidad de tener una
conversación con christina que cambió la
forma de abordar este tipo de proyectos
christina con su equipo de profesionales
sanitarios en atención especializada en
hospitales trabajó con un equipo de
ingenieros en una idea que parecía
genial desarrollaron una potente
plataforma de gestión de pacientes
crónicos para que al darlos de alta
pudieran seguirles remotamente y
atenderles en aquellas zonas aisladas
socialmente aquellas zonas rurales en
donde vivían parecía una buena idea pero
cuando estuvo desarrollada en
implantarla se encontraron con barreras
y dificultades les cristina y su equipo
se encontró con que los pacientes las
familias y los profesionales
sociosanitarios que tenían que
interactuar con la plataforma no veían
el valor que ellos habían pensado cuando
estuvieron diseñando la
esto hizo cambiar mi perspectiva cambiar
mi forma de ver el mundo y pensar en que
algo teníamos que hacer para transformar
nuestro entorno como debíamos para
ejercer un rol activo en la sociedad y
comprometernos con la agenda 2030 que
defendemos con s o de c3 de salud que
tanta necesidad tenemos porque tenemos
que liderar el presente para crear el
futuro porque las enfermedades crónicas
han venido para quedarse la tecnología
es la llave para ofrecer la
sostenibilidad del sistema y para eso
tenemos tres formas de abordarlo la
innovación tecnológica desde un punto de
vista de aporte de valor
el diseño centrado en el usuario en la
parte más humana y el enfoque sistémico
y la generación de alianzas
en la parte innovación tecnológica este
año de pandemia ha habido multitud de
soluciones tecnológicas enfocadas a
resolver problemas de salud en pacientes
kobe pero también en aquellos pacientes
crónicos que por la situación no podían
verse atendidos adecuadamente todas las
empresas todas las soluciones
compitiendo por un mismo cliente por un
mismo océano rojo en un mismo océano
rojo y hoy estoy aquí para proponer es
cambiar de estrategia para retarlos a
todos a los ingenieros a los diseñadores
de producto pero también a los
profesionales de la salud que tienen que
salir de sus silos y trabajar
conjuntamente porque cuando miramos de
forma distinta creamos soluciones
distintas porque cuando trabajamos las
relaciones es ahí donde en las
relaciones aportamos valor a el proceso
porque tenemos que salir de lo obvio ser
creativos despertar ese lado nuestro y
buscar el océano azul
nos permitan hacer el reboot que estamos
buscando y vamos a contar una historia
concreta os voy a presentar a antonio
antonio tiene 78 años y vive en un
pequeño pueblo en la zona norte de
castilla-león aislado no hay hospital no
hay centro de salud y tampoco hay ni
siquiera un consultorio solo una
enfermera que pasa consulta una vez a la
semana
antonio se ha caído y se ha roto la
cadera una patología que es la que en
segundo lugar
consume más recursos en el sistema
sanitario y antonio se le da el alta
pero él quiere volver a su entorno
quiere volver a vivir en su polvo de
rupert a su calidad de vida y su
independencia quiere volver a caminar y
continuar con la vida antes de la
fractura de cadera pero no es el único
en 2040
se espera que haya 500.000 personas que
sufran una fractura de cadera en españa
y en 2050 4 millones y medio
creéis que la tecnología puede hacer
algo por ellos creéis que la tecnología
puede desarrollar soluciones más allá de
la telemedicina en la teleconsulta que
generen oportunidades para que estas
personas sean atendidas sus necesidades
de salud y no les queremos
otras preocupaciones porque pensar que
esa plataforma de gestión de pacientes
crónicos nos permitía recoger datos y
nos permitía informar a antonio pero
también cambiar la medicación eso
pensamos que era una podía ser una
solución pero cuando se lo dijimos a
antonio y ala como dignidad donde vivía
estábamos generando les un problema
porque un cambio de medicación necesita
un nuevo medicamento y para eso
necesitas llegar a una farmacia y
antonio vive a 30 km de la farmacia más
cercana
antonio recibe la visita de sus
familiares con suerte en el fin de
semana con lo cual no estamos
solucionando su necesidad le estamos
generando un problema que no tenía
quizás soluciones más fáciles más
sencillas es la respectiva de la
innovación frugal nos permiten
desarrollar productos desarrollar
dispositivos que le permitan estar en su
entorno y que nos permitan recoger datos
objetivos quizá integrados en una muleta
en un andador que él va a tener que
utilizar y que puedan permitir a los
médicos a los profesionales sanitarios
tomar las decisiones que necesitan para
actuar cuando correspondan y por qué
estamos aquí hablando
de valor del valor de las personas de
centrarnos en lo que ellos piensan
de pensar no sólo en los pacientes sino
también sus familiares que se preocupan
por ellos y en los profesionales de la
salud que se preocupan cuando dan de
alta un paciente como antonio y no saben
qué va a pasar y temen que reingrese en
los pocos días con una complicación de
su patología que no debería haber
ocurrido pero también de las empresas de
las tecnológicas las universidades que
están desarrollando e innovando en
productos si los juntamos a todos si
creamos si trabajamos conjuntamente
conseguimos engancharles favorecer el
cambio porque tenéis que trabajar con
atención sanitaria basada en valor y el
valor no es más que cambiar la forma en
la que nos relacionamos con el sistema
todos los agentes involucrados en ello
valor es pensar no sólo en la parte
clínica en resolver la necesidad puntual
de la enfermedad sino en abordarlo desde
una perspectiva bio psicosocial desde la
perspectiva de cómo afecta a la
enfermedad en el entorno en la familia
en esas personas que quieren vivir solas
que no quieren irse a vivir a una ciudad
con un hijo que no quieren ir a una
residencia
es generar impacto cambiar el sistema y
organizarnos y para ello tenemos
herramientas de diseño centra en el
usuario para ello tenemos que ponernos
estas gafas de realidad que nos permitan
ver las realidades de la mirada antonio
pero también desde la mirada del médico
que necesita ver las cosas de una manera
sentir que piensan que sienten que
quieren qué miedos tienen y qué
fortalezas porque ellos quieren que les
resolvamos una necesidad concreta y si
no lo hacemos así podemos tener ideas
geniales pero que estén resolviendo el
problema equivocado porque todos ellos
todos los agentes involucrados quieren
hacer uso de la tecnología pero como un
medio y no como el fin de la tecnología
como la herramienta para conseguir lo
que ellos necesitan pero conseguir
aquello que va más allá de los
beneficios funcionales de beneficios
tangibles pero los intangibles que son
los importantes para ellos los
emocionales los relacionales la
comunicación con los sueños y con los
profesionales sanitarios y del otro lado
de la balanza el precio las
inseguridades las incomodidades que les
bajen
aquí está el problema de muchas de las
soluciones que tenemos hoy en día que
solo nos fijamos en el primero de los
puntos a cada uno de los lados en los
beneficios funcionales y en el precio y
no tenemos en cuenta todo lo demás
antonio quiere seguir viviendo solo
quiere seguir viviendo en su entorno y
como en muchos otros pacientes crónicos
tenemos que poner ese cambio de mirada y
actuar cambiando la estrategia como
empresas como entidades apostando por
una transformación y por un cambio un
cambio que genere impacto y que deje
huella pero ojo cuando hablamos de
impacto no hablamos de atender a miles
de pacientes de que nuestra solución va
a ser la que resuelva el problema de los
datos de las necesidades de los
pacientes cuando hablamos de impacto
hablamos de generar un cambio a corto al
medio y a largo plazo y que sea
sostenible y que realmente transforme la
sociedad en la que vivimos en
consecuencia con la agenda 2030 y eso
sólo puede hacerse con un tercer punto
desde una tercera perspectiva la
generación de alianzas un sistema de
innovación que incorpore los cuatro
elementos del entorno que incorpora la
universidad a las facultades de
ingeniería a las facultades de ciencias
de la salud dónde tenemos que enseñar a
nuestros alumnos a pensar de forma
diferente a trabajar en la frontera del
conocimiento a trabajar juntos dejemos
de estar trabajando en silos y de forma
aislada
tenemos que pensar en alianzas con los
hospitales con el tejido productivo con
las tecnológicas pero también con los
inversores que finalmente son los que
van a hacer posible que las startups
salgan al mercado y se implanten tenemos
que trabajar en la brecha digital pero
no solo en la brecha generacional parece
que la brecha digital es solo que
nuestros mayores no trabajan la
tecnología como lo hacemos los más
jóvenes y como lo van a hacer los que
vienen de atrás la brecha digital va más
allá de eso va a una brecha social a una
recha económica españa hay más de 26 mil
pueblos con más de 10 habitantes que no
tienen infraestructuras para poder
soportar internet y por tanto la
tecnología que les vamos a ofrecer a
nivel de salud digital con esta
situación 13 millones de personas viven
en esa situación sólo el 25 de nuestros
mayores de 75 años han accedido a
internet en los últimos tres meses algo
nos tiene que dar de pensar en eeuu
sobre el 38 por ciento de las personas
que han utilizado la telemedicina en
este último año estaban preparadas para
ello por tanto quiero que hoy salgamos
con la convicción de que algo tiene que
cambiar de que tenemos que salir de esos
silos tenemos que dejar de trabajar
aisladamente para lograr un cambio
global en el sistema y tenemos tres
soluciones al pie de la mesa una
innovación tecnológica que aporte valor
y busquen esos océanos azules donde no
hay competencia donde estamos aportando
más valor a menos coste a menor coste
que trabajemos en el diseño central del
usuario pero poniéndonos esas gafas de
realidad esas gafas que nos permiten
pensar como antonio pensar cómo
christina pensar como ellos y ver las
realidades de este otro mundo y desde un
enfoque sistémico generador de alianzas
que permitan resolver las necesidades
reales a tiempo real y de una manera
sostenible
hoy más que nunca me alegra haber tenido
aquella conversación con ella hace cinco
años me alegra dar a él me he puesto las
gafas para ver la realidad donde antonio
y tantos otros como antonio me alegra
haber podido impulsar proyectos con
impacto
hoy seguimos aquí hacemos reboot para
empezar
[Aplausos]